good morning J is calm food a past being
the first Speaker of the day I have to
you know be the one for today that
points out once again how lucky we are
to be standing in this you know sitting
in this venue getting to listen to the
brilliant minds of our day sharing
things and they will be coming up later
but until then I'm going to talk for a
few minutes the title of my talk as it
says is NBC Mozart Violin Concerto
versus model-view-controller and you may
be like okay old guy on stage
model-view-controller that makes sense
the truth is I'm not going to mention
model-view-controller probably even once
it just makes a really good pun with
Mozart Violin Concerto this is me I'm
from Vancouver and in Canada though I
was originally born in the States please
don't hold that against me I've been in
Canada for 20 years my current role is
I'm head instructor of lighthouse labs
which is a software development bootcamp
that means my job is to teach people
everyday about coding I have been a web
developer for 19 years
I remember when we still had like the
macro media preload images rollover in
JavaScript like that was advanced
JavaScript for a web page I remember
those days but this is also me I started
off with a degree in music from Columbus
State University in Columbus Georgia
and my original goal in life was that I
was going to perform in opera orchestras
and ballet orchestras and musicals all
around the world and live that kind of
Jet Set tuxedo life and that was going
to be my world but interestingly in 1998
I got introduced to the world of web
development computers had always been a
hobby of mine I'd always loved using
computers and I found this this web
thing that people were talking about and
using HTML and using what barely passed
for CSS at that point and I had a couple
really good mentors who introduced me to
what best practices were and how to get
involved and I found that the web was a
perfect canvas if I could imagine it it
could go on the screen and that
motivated me that move
and my hobby and my career swapped
places in the span of literally about
four days during which time I built
probably the worst webpage ever it was
purple it had fish at the top there was
a big forum where every input field was
about this wide on an 800 by 600 screen
of course but I'm still an active
musician I performed principal horn with
the Vancouver Pops Orchestra and a few
other organizations in Vancouver and
it's very much a part of my life and
with something being that much a part of
your life
you end up analyzing the ways in which
you can get better in all the parts of
your life and I started to notice as I
progressed some crossovers between music
and technology and they weren't just you
know the common ones like I listen to
music while I'm coding that that's an
obvious one as I this I realized that
what I was searching for more than
anything else is I was searching for a
way for my music to make my technology
better and the creative side of me the
analytical side of me started having a
conversation and if you've ever had that
many voices in your head well you
probably need medication but I found
some some interesting parallels there
and so I figured this was something I
could get up onstage and I could talk
about because approach for us as
developers is everything but it is a
tech presentation so I have to have an
obligatory Jeff so I wanted to get that
one out of the way early and I want to
start off this morning with a little bit
of culture if the sound would play
that gives gives you a preview of what's
coming up
Noyce I promise this worked about half
an hour ago
yeah
which is weird because it was virtual
for perfect
and now for some culture that was the
entrance for the violin soloist to the
Mozart Violin Concerto number one that's
15 seconds of your life that you won't
get back but it's 15 seconds of your
life that you listen to something that
you probably weren't paying attention to
the fact that there was a tremendous
amount of structure and technique and
things going on behind it you're just
like oh hey Mozart first thing in the
morning not bad but I want to take that
that clip and I want you to now listen
to it again in your head I'm not gonna
play it again but listen to it in your
head again and think about the fact that
there is a very solid structure there
there's a very definite set of technique
that is being demonstrated there and the
reason I point these things out is
because when we go to use a web
application as consumers because we're
all consumers of the web as well as
builders of the web but when we go to
use a web application we don't think
about the structure that's going on when
you sit down and you use Instagram or
Facebook you're not thinking about the
load balancers you're not thinking about
the caching or the Reedus sessions or
whatever may happen to be going on
behind the scenes you're just using an
app and that's fine and we we think we
might peel the curtain back and think
about what's going on underneath but
music has that same structure and so
this usually brings up the question of
who cares great music has structure gone
we knew that but if I'm going to talk
about these parallels then I actually
have to start pointing out some very
specific areas where we should care we
as developers should care and the reason
is we as musicians and developers get to
think similarly quick show of hands how
many of you have spent at least one year
of your life
either taking using music lessons
playing in a musical group singing a
chorus something like that fair number
that's going to help me quite a bit
users care the reason users care is
because software and music are both a
craft if you go to the symphony and you
are listening to lang lang or Yo Yo Ma
or Itzhak Perlman or any of the the
great great performers of our day you
are seeing an absolute virtuoso a craft
you know a crafts person at work very
similarly you know when we go and we use
a lot of the you know powerful and
well-built apps that we use every day we
are seeing a craft at work when we see
someone up here live coding and we see
the the techniques that they are
demonstrating we're watching a
craftsperson
at work that's impressive and I would
much rather eat at a Michelin star
restaurant where the chef is a
consummate master of their craft than at
Burger King
for example the craftsmanship of our
work matters and I say that you should
care because I said earlier approaches
everything if we can get better at
approaching our craft we will make
better products and I'm going to stand
up here I'm going to say something
slightly controversial but I won't break
the code of conduct not that kind of
controversial and it's that for all the
work that we do we don't get hired to
code there's not a single person in this
room that is employed to code we get
hired to build products that's what we
do we support the benefit that data is
going to give to a user
we provide features that give those
users benefit and ultimately our
products generate revenue for our
company's revenue turns into our
paychecks and let's face it while we
care about our craft and we care about
the creativity we also care about
getting paid so you should care approach
makes better preventer approach makes
better products and I should care
because I decided to be brave and talk
about this so I have to care about
let's talk a little bit about Mozart
this is your history lesson for the
morning Mozart was born in 715 1756
lived until 1791 for those of you that
are doing the math that means he died at
about 35 36 years of age so he had a
very short life most of the things that
you've heard about him are true don't
pay attention in the movie Amadeus it's
completely farcical but he was
absolutely a virtuoso of his time he was
a child prodigy he was composing his
first opera at the age of five he was
performing in public at the age of four
like huge salon performances where
hundreds of people would come to listen
to him play he was absolutely the rock
star of his time and interestingly in
his very short life I he composed a
tremendous body of work by the time he
died he had over 600 completed works
that is prolific in a way that we can't
fathom really as developers if I was to
ask for a show of hands I doubt any of
you would be able to raise your hand and
say that you have 600 completed products
that you have built in your lifetime and
these are 600 products that are out in
the marketplace that people are
consuming and using and other people are
are being inspired by and this is just a
short list of what he was able to
contribute in his lifetime I mean 22
operas those are huge and he wrote 22 of
them and had two more that were
unfinished on top of that I'm 44 I got
pants on this morning like that's my
accomplishment and trust me I'm happy
about that like thank you right
so what I wanted to find was taking the
example of someone like Mozart who's
famous for being very prolific and
having tons and tons of works that he
was able to complete I wanted to figure
out how I could hack my productivity if
I could use someone like Mozart or Bach
or Beethoven or any of the great masters
of music and look at how they built
their products look at how they
approached their craft and see if there
was something that I could learn from it
in order to make me a better developer I
mean I you know I build JavaScript all
the time I know several languages I've
been around the block not my first rodeo
but I wanted to get better I always want
to get better and so I started to look
at what approach they were using
specifically Mozart being so prolific
what approach they were using that I
could be inspired by and I had to ask
myself what does it have to do with code
and initially it wasn't there wasn't a
lot that was forthcoming because while a
lot of has been written about Mozart's
life nobody really sat down and
interviewed him Barbara Walters style to
you know figure out what made him tick
back in you know 1780 or something like
that you know we didn't have TMZ you
know following around with pictures so
it was a little bit harder to figure out
so I had to do just a bit of analysis
based on what I knew and what I could
find and there were a couple things that
came out that allowed me to take lessons
of Mozart's life and apply them to code
and the first the biggest was structure
one of the things that mozart is
absolutely famous for is the structure
of his music he pretty much defined the
Classical period of music much to the
chagrin of many other composers of that
age Mozart was seen as the paradigm very
much you know we might look at say Dan
Abramov's
egg head tutorials as the the paradigm
of how to learn Redux
although I know all of you have that
perfect blog post that explains it way
better than he does it's not like you
wrote it or anything but structure was
important to to Mozart
and our apps have structure you know I
can put up this diagram and we can all
trace through it and see you know
there's a service okay we've got cloud
storage we've got external thing for
sessions we understand the workflow here
but we're very careful about building
structures like this whether it is just
a simple web app you know even though
like a one-page or and express whether
it is a complex bordering uncomplicated
you know distributed micro service
architecture and everything that would
go into that our apps have a very
definite structure in fact the
structures that we use we tend to call
them design patterns and that can go
from everything like the async if he's
that Jonathan was talking about
yesterday turn Ares all the way up to
entire app structure like this well
musicians composers particularly have a
structure to their music the one that
Mozart was famous for perfecting was
what's called the Sonata Allegro form
and I promise that you looking at this
is the same effect that musicians have
when they look at this but this is a
very particular form that most of the
music that Mozart wrote follows in fact
the piece that we listened to earlier if
we were to listen to the whole thing and
this was a music theory class and I had
four hours of your life that I could put
into analyzing it we would be able to
break down very easily onto this diagram
that piece of music once you've heard it
a couple times you almost can't unhear
it the exposition the development the
regular recapitulation they're very
obvious as structure of the music we
envision our applications as whole
systems a lot of times we're responsible
for one small piece of it a lot of times
we're responsible for architecting the
entire broad hole but we see them as as
whole systems but they have structures
inside of them this is the structure of
a few I'm going to go back 75 years
further in musical history to Johann
Sebastian Bach 1685 to 1750 not that you
care
Bach was famous for the few
which is four completely independent
lines anywhere from two to five actually
but four completely independent lines of
music four different melodies being
played together at the same time to form
a whole new piece of music sounds a lot
like concurrency asynchronous operations
parallel processing a lot of the things
that we would have in our applications
on a daily basis second big piece was
approach structure matters okay I know I
need to focus on the structure but then
I need to think about the approach how
am I going to think about my application
my product my composition before I write
it and I realized that I had to look at
it the same way structurally that a
musician would look at a piece of music
and musicians especially since a lot of
you have experience we have two ways of
thinking we have the horizontal or
melody and we have the vertical which is
our harmony so horizontally how can I
think about things and one of the the
quotes that's great comes from Edward de
Bono and 1967 so it's even older than I
am
but he talks about how lateral thinking
is stepping to one side laterally and
thinking about something in an
unconventional way taking steps to solve
a problem that you may not have
otherwise thought were the
straightforward way to solve a problem
we've all had that moment typically we
call it you know being clever or mad
hacks or one of those terms that
justifies us doing something that might
be a little bit unconventional Mozart
did this all the time melodically in
Mozart's works he did things that were
considered unconventional for the time
but now are considered absolutely 100%
standard if he's when they first came
out you know when we first started
seeing this this pattern emerge it was
considered unconventional in a wild and
you know cowboy coding and yes I just
did finger guns but they were you know
that was an example of lateral thinking
being applied to the craft of building a
piece of music this is actually the the
written out music for what you just
listened to a few minutes
ago and there is a very definite
horizontal flow the melody of a piece of
music is the horizontal flow of that
music when we're thinking about that
progressing over time you know this
becomes a timeline as much as it does
just a direction that the music is going
this is music borrowed from the theme of
a very popular TV show which involves
dragons and a lot of naked people whose
name I won't say for copyright reasons
but it rhymes with rain of Bones and
there's a couple things that are really
interesting in this piece of music and
for those of you that can read music
notation you're probably humming it in
your head but I've taken the liberty of
applying a couple of carefully placed
green arrows to show that even the
structure of this music is designed to
move it forward the melody is actually
designed to have you feeling that
anticipation it's almost like when we
build I don't know a tour on an app that
we've just built and we're trying to
draw that user in or when we monetize a
landing page and have calls to action
that they're going to draw the user
forward there is a pattern here of
thinking horizontally through time and
what is going to move our listener to a
piece of music or our user in web
application what is going to move them
forward in time algorithms a very wise
humble man who I I won't name though I
will say that he is bald and charming
and incredibly handsome came up with
this quote in the middle of the night
one night but algorithms are the
melodies of an application and this was
my aha moment this was my aha moment
where I could say this is how this is
that crux where the parallels really
start to click together these steps that
we take to process the data that we are
giving our users access to those are the
steps that move forward in time like the
individual notes that I would put into a
melody to have it move forward in time
our algorithms are the melodies of our
app when we're thinking horizontally as
a developer you know we'll take Robin as
a user Robin's gonna click a link that's
going to send to get requests from the
client clients going to hit the server
servers going to make an API call maybe
to some popular service that serves up
JSON data very nicely that API is going
to return some data we might take that
and send it into something like Watson
in order to analyze it and the server is
going to get data back from Watson build
a response and it's going to send it
back to Robin this is a horizontal
progression of steps that we can follow
very similar to how we might follow the
melody of a piece of music fizzbuzz is
another great example we all know how
fizzbuzz works and if you don't well
it's the worst Tech interview question
ever you just need to memorize ten ways
to do it that are all in one line in
different languages and then just ready
regurgitate it when you go for an
interview but this is a perfect example
of how we have a very linear set of
steps that we follow even though there's
some conditional branches in there but
there's a very linear progression over
time that leads us from one point to
another from problem to solution so as
our code moves from one step to another
the thinking that fuels our solutions is
linear it is horizontal and a lot of
times in the best cases when we are
doing something unconventional that
maybe hasn't been done before its
lateral let's talk about the vertical
now that other axis we call it a stack
we vertically arrange the components of
our applications and we call it a stack
when we have words like that you know
Hugh stack tree these are words that we
might use every day and they have
multiple meanings depending on whether
I'm pointing at you know a maple tree in
Vancouver Canada or whether I am you
know pointing at a directory structure
for example but we call it a stack
because there is a vertical relationship
in this case ember or react or view or
whatever your drug of choice is for
building your front-end is going to talk
to node nodes going to talk to Postgres
that's all sitting inside of a doctor
container running on a Linux server
somewhere you know and I'm not even
counting in the network layer here for
how we're how we're connecting to that
but it's a stack and it's very vertical
we code vertically as well as
horizontally all of these different
techniques here that we might use have
to do at any moment in time there's an
entire relationship of our application
in our data at that moment in time if
any click at any debug step if we were
putting breakpoints on every single line
of our code there's a vertical
relationship that we have there with the
different technologies that we brought
in and the interesting part about that
is that becomes one of the ways that we
have a challenge as developers our
challenge is to have our work be ignored
when I talked about sitting down and
using an application that had a great
amount of craft to it ideally the user
should forget that someone sat down and
typed that all out the user should
forget that someone had to debug and
ended up screaming at their computer the
user should forget you know whether we
were rubber ducking to solve that
problem or whether it took a stand-up
scrum of 10 minutes like the user
doesn't care ideally the user should
never have to think about the work that
we put into our application we're
building experiences for them we're
building products for them our problem
solving in our vertical architecture
should be transparent you know when we
have DNS problems or CloudFlare goes
down or you know github is down for
whatever reason there are a lot of
things that happen the DNS outage that
happened in eastern North America a
couple months ago when things like that
happen it affects our users but our
ultimate goal is that they should never
ever notice musicians have it just as
hard unfortunately this is a bit of
music from the Mozart Violin Concerto
I've taken the liberty of applying some
green lines to where the beats of the
music are as a musician especially if
you are a soloist you have to make sure
that as you are playing the meter of
your music the meter of the melody that
you're playing lines up with your
accompaniment you know just to go off on
your merry way and you know hope that
they catch up the same way that we
wouldn't want our react apt to just go
off and start processing things and
making assumptions about data without
ever actually querying the server for it
that would be bad
similarly when we're thinking vertically
as a musician we have the concept of
harmony basically are we in tune so I've
circled an E flat major chord here if
you don't know what that is smile and
nod but the soloist on the top line
there has to make sure that that b-flat
that they are playing is going to be in
tune with the rest of the ensemble
you've probably all at one point or
another had to go to your nieces or
nephews
you know grade six band concert or
something like that and you know you had
that that moment of just cringing
because of the way it sounded
even though you were proud of them for
what they were able to accomplish of
course but tuning and being in harmony
matters and so this was where my second
AHA happened in thinking about this and
it came comes from this quote in tune on
time this quote comes from a gentleman
named dr. Frederic Finnell who was a
very famous conductor in the United
States he was the master of bands and
orchestras at Indiana University he was
about this tall he was a vicious little
beast of a man but he was a brilliant
musician and I had the privilege of
performing under his baton once and we
were having a particularly hard day in
rehearsal and he put down his baton and
he said ok I just want you to understand
one thing the process of making music is
very simple and he said let me let me
draw an analogy for baseball and
baseball being the quote sport of
America and all of that terrible way to
spend an afternoon but good beer and bad
hotdogs
he made analogy to baseball players and
he said baseball players are paid
millions of dollars a year to hit
one-third of the pitches that are thrown
to them if they are exceptional they're
hitting 333 and he said musicians on the
average are barely paid minimum wage to
play 100% of the notes that are put in
front of them this this was the the aha
moment as I remembered this quote any so
what he said was musicians all we have
to do to be successful is we have to
play in tune on time if we can do that
the music will be beautiful everything
after that is just making music this is
all the technique you ever need and so I
got to thinking about that and I got
thinking about this in tune on time idea
when it comes to my applications and so
I asked myself can we apply that
mentality to development can we strip
away a lot of the the complexity that we
tend to add to the process and the
approach of building an application and
can we apply this mentality and of
course another famous quote came to mind
so I had to use that one and yes we can
Obama got elected on these three words
that in Twitter but if I'm looking at
musicians verse developers and how how
this in tune on time idea applies
musicians tell a story art is how we
decorate space music is how we decorate
time and a performer is stringing
together notes and melodies stacked on
top of harmonies but a developer
developers are offering solutions we are
building products we're giving access to
data the benefits users through our
implementation so an algorithm
implemented into an architecture creates
a product and so now a good user
experience I can define this by drawing
these parallels and saying a good a user
experience is one where the app runs in
tune on time when it just works for the
user when our approach has been to you
the lateral thinking to be aware of the
structure the underlying architecture of
our application to be very aware of that
algorithm that's progressing from start
to finish and if we can get our apps to
run in tune on time then we're gonna
have fantastic products I do have a
shameless plug please feel free to buy
my book I just published a book about
project planning putting a lot of these
ideas into place I'm very opinionated no
surprise I'm a developer and I'd love to
see these ideas getting shared because I
think they make a huge difference in the
way I approach applications now and
that's all I have to talk about to you
today thank you very much